Let me tell you a secret.
Wars are being fought for your attention
and today we're going to be looking at
the new war that's been going on as well
as looking back to see what we can learn
from past wars.
The new battlefield is on youtube and it
involves one really annoying tactic.
Morning Guys,
how's her?
When do I pick the kids?
[inaudible]
welcome to the excitement.
Wars were fake excitement and hype draws
in more viewers and gets people to watch
longer.
If you want to be a part of this,
you have to get excited,
like really excited.
In fact,
if they think you're going to have a
seizure or a heart attack,
pets about the right level,
but even though that will keep views,
I don't think fake excitement is a good
thing.
It eventually makes excitement and hype
on Youtube meaningless because everyone
is overusing it,
but I'm not going to hate on any
individual.
They're just playing the system
exploiting a weakness in our attention.
I just wanted to talk about the
potential effects and what we can do
about it because believe it or not,
we've already seen this warp play out
before,
twice.
Both of them bear a striking resemblance
to the excitement of wars and I think we
can examine them to learn lessons about
our own wars today.
Have you ever heard of the loudness
wars?
It started in the 1940s when sound
engineers began to realize that louder
music stands out on Juke boxes,
so they began telling the record labels
to record louder so people started
overusing compressors to artificially
raise the volume of their whole song to
be as loud as possible.
And the reason raising the volume
artificially matters is because it
destroys something called dynamic range.
Basically.
That's the difference between the
quietest and loudest part of a song and
it's hugely responsible for conveying
emotion and tone.
The problem with the loudness wars is,
as Matt may feel,
puts it when there's no quiet,
there can be no loud.
The first few seconds of Beethoven's
fifth symphony illustrates this really
well.
Pay Close attention to the volume and
how it affects the tone of the piece.
The reason you can really feel those
loud moments is because of the quiet
ones right before it,
and we can see these peaks and valleys
of intensity in the visual way form of a
song.
Here's the song.
Before that loudness wars really
escalated and here's a way form during
the loudness wars,
simultaneously as the loudness wars were
going on,
there was a similar war going on in the
media,
a wharf sensationalism with Fox News
being one of the first 24 hour news
networks founded in 1996 people soon
became aware that sensationalist,
even partisan show's got a lot more
views than moderate even handed ones.
Because of this,
several similar news programs were
created on the other side of the aisle.
Both sides vying for the attention of
the television viewer.
This escalation in sensationalism
resulted in news clips like this.
This does this offend you,
this word.
A lot of people are shocked.
A massive gas line.
Rutgers,
could it happen in your neighborhood?
Marijuana,
could it be in your neighborhood and is
America ready?
Is the u s next is America dangerously
under four pair.
The flip flop is the new sneaker,
but behind the Sandal nursing,
serious danger,
not only lack of sleep,
it can kill you it sleeping too much
and no one critique the dangers of this
hyper sensationalism better than John
Stewart.
If we amplify everything we hear
nothing.
Okay,
sounds a little bit like matt may film.
He echoes this thought later in an
interview.
Now the problem is how do you keep
people watching it?
Oh,
Jay's not going to kill someone every
day,
so that's gone.
So what do you have to do?
You have to elevate the passion of
everything else that happens that might
even be somewhat mundane and elevate it
to the extent that this is breaking
news.
The aggregate effect of that is that you
begin to lose the lexicon.
You begin to lose any meaning of what
breaking news means or urgent or look at
this or dangerous.
You know,
this is a an arms race.
The language then has to become sharper,
louder to cut through more and more of
the noise.
And when I'm saying is maybe there is a
way to not engage in the idea,
not to accept the premise
Jon Stewart's mind.
The news had become an arms race to
become more sensationalist,
fantastic from the rest,
but it resulted in a loss of fidelity of
what is important,
just like the loudness wars,
but sensationalists wars were
obliterating the crescendos of real life
news by amplifying everything into
meaninglessness.
And now we come back to the excitement
wars.
All of these guys are emotional actors
playing to what they know that we want,
but just like in media and news,
it's getting to the point where we can
no longer distinguish what is actually
fun and exciting because people play
everything up as if it were so exciting.
But maybe we don't have to accept the
premise.
Here's something to remember.
These wars eventually get played out.
People get sick of the escalation and
insanity of it.
And we can see these effects happening
in the loudness wars where we've seen a
reduction in over compression since 2005
we've also seen a similar reaction into
sensationalist wars with the rise in
popularity of websites like politifact
fact check and all sides that seek to
lessen the sensationalism in politics
and seek unbiased.
We will never be rid of people trying to
exploit our biases,
whether it be towards volume
sensationalism or excitement.
But thankfully we can vote with our
views to not pay attention to those
people.
These wars are going to keep going,
but we don't have to be a part of it.
No.
Hey,
thanks for watching that video.
Uh,
we just hit 10,000
subscribers on this channel,
which is completely amazing.
I never thought it would be there and
thanks so much to those of you who have
been sharing my videos,
liking and commenting on them,
that just means so much to the channel
and really helps my channel grow.
I try not to use clickbait or too much
like kind of tricks.
So I really rely on you guys to get the
word out there kind of organically.
So thank you so much to those of you who
have done it and are going to continue
to do that.
And uh,
yeah,
I hope you enjoyed that video.
Let me know what you want to see next.